that vocal was just incredible that's
crazy you are incredible I'm just still
so stunned to hear that you're hearing
impaired a singer whose deaf blows away
the coaches of the voice with a
jaw-dropping blind audition I actually
wrote it into the script this season
that I'm going to win on Monday night
Ali
Ali four-year-old
s California Native
form her rendition
softly with
her
[Music]
those smooth vocals earned Ally chair
turns from coaches Chance the Rapper and
Kelly Clarkson it was amazing and while
her performance was a showstopper it's
what Ali told the coaches after the fact
that really wowed them a fun fact about
me is I am hearing impaired what I wear
two hearing aids I was born deaf I'm so
blessed to be able to share this Kelly
chance and their fellow coaches Niall
Horan and Blake Shelton were shocked by
the news and were quick to praise her
vocal chops your runs were so intricate
and cool and different that's a gift any
sort of adversity that you've had in
your life you are just jumping hurdles
here and it's incredible to watch that
vocal was just incredible you just have
an amazing voice and all the choices
that you were making felt very Soulful
but after all all that praise Ali had to
make a choice and she ultimately joined
team Kelly it's a good season E.T caught
up with the season 23 coaches ahead of
the premiere where Kelly opened up about
competing with Blake during his last
season on the show I texted him if he
was gonna do it last year's I wanted to
make sure I was there Blake's been a
coach on The Voice since the show
premiered in 2011 and announced last
year that season 23 is his last has it
hit you yet that your time on The Voice
is coming to an end so I don't think
it's really going to hit me until
uh the the last episode it's probably
going to be an emotional night that last
night I mean my God it's been 23 see 12
years it's unbelievable it's to all the
life that's happened and I met my wife
on there you know it just everything
good that could come from something like
that it
I maxed it out like he said Blake met
Gwen Stefani on the show in 2014 and the
two went on to get married in 2021. I'm
just so proud of him I mean he's brought
so much joy he's so talented as for
Kelly she insists she won't let any
sentimental feelings affect the
competition if he wins I am very happy
for him because that is super cool to
win on their last season and he's
literally this show and from its
conception but like I'm not like rooting
for him to win I'll be happy for him if
he does but I'm obviously trying to win
myself and with Ali on her team Kelly
has a pretty decent shot at winning and
so I came to see him
[Music]